I come from Egypt which is also called
on mat dunya the mother of the world
it's a rich country filled with stories
of rebellion stories of civilization
triumph and downfall and the rich
religious ethnic cultural and linguistic
diversity growing up in such environment
I became a strong believer in the power
of storytelling as I searched for the
media mother to sell my story I stumbled
upon graphic design I would like to
share with you a project of how graphic
design can bring the Arabic language to
life but first let me tell you why I
want to do this
I believe that graphic design can change
the world at least in my very own city
of Cairo it helped overthrow two
separate dictators as you can see from
those photos the power and potential of
graphic design as a tool for positive
change is undeniably strong each of 2011
revolution was also a grassroots design
revolution everyone became a creator
people were the real designers and just
overnight Cairo was flooded with posters
signage graffiti visual communication
was the medium that spoke far louder
than words on a population of over 90
million voices were suppressed for
almost 30 years it was precisely this
political and social suppression coupled
with decades of colonialism and
mis-education that slowly eroded the
significance of the Arabic script in the
region all of these countries once used
Arabic that was just the green and the
blue to put it simply the Arabic script
is dying in post-colonial Arab countries
functioning in an increasingly
globalized world it is a growing alarm
that less and less people are using the
Arabic script to communicate as I was
studying my masters in Italy
I noticed myself missing Arabic I miss
looking at the letters digesting their
meaning so one day I walked into one of
the biggest libraries in Italy in search
of an Arabic book I was surprised to
find that this is what they had under
the category of Arabic middle-eastern
books fear terrorism and destruction
one word Isis my heart ached that this
is how we portray to the world even from
a literary perspective I asked myself
whatever happened to the world renowned
writers like Nagi mahfooz Khalil Gibran
iconic poets like Madonna B nazar Kabini
think about this the culture products of
an entire region of the world as rich as
diverse have been deemed redundant if
not ignored altogether the culture
products of an entire region of the
world have been barred from imparting
any kind of real impact on global media
productions in contemporary social
discourse and then I reminded myself of
my number one belief design can change
the world all you need is for someone to
catch a glimpse of your work feel
connect and so I started I thought about
how can I stop the world from seeing us
as evil as terrorists of this planet and
start perceiving us as equals fellow
humans how can I save and honor the
Arabic script and share it with other
people other cultures and then it hit me
what if I combined the two most
significant symbols of innocence and
Arab identity maybe then people could
resonate
what's more pure innocent and fun as
Lego it's a universal child so you play
with them you build with them and with
them you imagine endless possibilities
my Eureka moment was to find a bilingual
solution for Arabic
occasion because effective communication
and education is the road to more
tolerant communities however the
advocate latin scripts not only
represent different worlds but also
create technical difficulties for both
eastern and western communities on daily
basis there are so many reasons why I
became Latin or different but here are
some of the main ones yes both used
upwards and downward strokes but have
completely different baselines
eirick tends to be more calligraphic and
connectivity is important to the Arabic
language whose letters has to be mostly
joined in order to articulate a given
word it also uses an entirely different
system of punctuation and diacritics but
most importantly Arabic has no capital
letters instead it has four different
letter forms initial medial isolated and
final I want to introduce the Arabic
language to young learners foreign
speakers but most importantly help
refugees integrate to their host
societies through creating a bilingual
learning system a two-way flow of
communication and I called it let's play
the idea is to simply create a fun and
engaging way of learning modern Standard
Arabic through Lego these are the two
words let's play every colored bar marks
an Arabic letter as you can see the
letter E is explained in form sound and
examples of words and function in
addition to the equivalent in Latin
together the form of fun pocketbook with
the 29 Iraq letters in there for
different forms plus a 400 word
dictionary so this is how the page looks
like you have the letter the
transliteration in Latin and a
description underneath I'll take you for
the process so first in my tiny studio
in Florence I built the letters I
photographed each letter separately and
then I retouched every letter and chose
the correct color backgrounds and high
faces to use ultimately I created the
full letter set which is 29 letters x 4
different for
that's a hundred and sixteen letter bill
just in one week I believe that
information should and can be fun
portable this book is the final product
which I would eventually like to publish
and translate into as many languages in
the world
so that Arabic teaching and learning
becomes fun easy and accessible globally
with this book I hope to save my
nation's beautiful scripts working on
this project was a form of visual
meditation like a Sufi dance a prayer to
a better planet one set of building
blocks made two languages Lego is just a
metaphor it's because we're all made of
the same building unit is that I can see
a future where the barriers between
people will come tumbling down so no
matter how ugly the world around us gets
or how many discouraging books on Isis
the terrorist group and not Aziz the
ancient Egyptian goddess continued to be
published I will keep building one
colorful world chakram which means thank
you